wo ist dein ding
[Musik]
ich musste die büros verkaufen und wo
arbeitet er jetzt zu hause oder in cafés
es ist schwierig aber es geht immerhin
muss ich niemanden entlassen
hast du manchmal aufträge ich meine
wovon ich rede gerade mit ein paar
kleineren firmen die sich für unsere
arbeit interessieren
es sieht ganz gut aus und wenn das
klappt können wir die schulden bald
abbezahlen und du arbeitest wald bei
jahre
du kannst dich ja auch noch bei mir
bewerben zuerst mal hier eine ausbildung
dafür muss ich eine sprachprüfung machen
wofür brauchst du diese ausbildung wenn
du die sprachprüfungen gemacht hast
kannst du doch auch studieren aber ich
will nicht studieren
du willst also wirklich lieber zwei
raten mechatroniker werden
aber wovon willst du leben willst du
dein geld verdienen mit kaputten
fahrrädern
ich weiß ja nicht wie es dir geht aber
ich habe keine schulden
ich bin ja nur dass du jetzt keinen
fehler machst ok worum geht es hier
eigentlich
ich muss nicht reich werden
ich würde es mir meine arbeit gefällt
dass wir unseren eltern
wieso sollte ich wir rufen sie gemeinsam
an wird zeit dass wir uns gegenseitig
helfen oder ok wenn es sein muss